翻訳: Makiko Miyashita
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
皆さん
私を見てどんなふうに思いますか？
外国人？
ハーフ？
どこから来たの？
ご飯ちゃんと食べてる？
学生？
だいたい皆さん
こんな感じでしょうか
そんな私が浜松インターナショナルスクールの
設立に携わり
初代校長をしていたと言ったら
どんな印象に変わりますか？
私はフィリピンで生まれ
フィリピンで幼少期を過ごしました
皆さんがご存じのように
フィリピンは
未だに貧富の差が激しい国です
私の生まれ育ったところは
マラテ地区と呼ばれるところです
スラムに毛が生えた程度の
簡素で前近代的な地域です
殺人は稀にあるものの
そこでは
強盗や薬物売買などが日常的に起こり
物心がついたころから
私はそのような光景を目にしていました
同じ地区で
特に貧しいとされている家庭では
自分と同年代の子供たちが
貧しさがゆえに
小学校に行くことが出来ませんでした
彼らは
毎日のように食べるものを求め
スリや強盗で手に入れたものを売ったり
薬物売買に加わったり
犯罪に手をどんどん染めていきます
そのような環境の中
実は
家族と離れたこの地で
私は
伯母に育てられました
母は日本で出稼ぎをしている時
父と国際結婚をしました
家族は日本で暮らしていましたが
私は日本というところが
ちょっと想像できなくて
家族についていくことができませんでした
しかし私は
幸いなことに伯母や周りから大切に守られ
大切に育ててもらったので
何の問題もなく過ごすことができました
その伯母さんに いつも教えられていたのは
「知識は唯一の財産」というものでした
これは貧富の差が激しいフィリピンでの
生きるための教えでした
知識を身に付けることを努力すれば
必ず上を目指せる
周りの環境に流されず打ち勝てる
私はこの言葉を胸に
毎日勉強し
小学校を５年で卒業しました
そして
思春期を迎えた頃
転機が訪れます
日本に住んでいる家族からの強い説得で
いよいよ移住することになったのです
飛行機の中で 友達や親戚から
頂いた手紙を読みながら
ドキドキとワクワクで日本へ向かいました
13歳まで
英語とタガログ語しか話していなかったため
日本語はゼロからのスタートでした
日本に来ても
すぐには学校へは通えず
父と母の３人で
市役所や
教育委員会へ相談に行きました
このころの私は
もちろん
話の内容を理解することはできませんでした
さて
私たちの住む浜松市には
どれぐらいの外国人がいると思いますか
ここ 浜松市では
人口が約80万人ですが
そのうち外国籍は
約２万１千人
そして驚くことに
81カ国もの人々が
この街で暮らしています
さらには
51%もの外国人が
永住権を持っています
こうした定住外国人
つまり
日本に生活の基盤を置いている
外国人の数に関しては
日本一の地区になっています
そして世界に名だたる企業も多く
本当に多様な国の人々が 暮らす街です
にもかかわらず
浜松市内や
近隣の市町村では
英語を第一言語とする
インターナショナルスクールがない
あっても
高額であったり
本当のエリートしか入学できなかったり
特別な学校になっています
そのため私は
日本の公立の中学校へ
転入することになりました
日本では飛び級制度は認められていませんので
年齢に沿って
もう一度中学１年生をやり直しです
当時の同級生や
担任の先生は
とても親切にしてくれましたが
予想していた通り
言葉の壁にぶつかりました
最初の頃は
何を話しているのか全く解らないので
周りが自分に怒っている
悪口を言っていると思えて
とても辛かったです
そして初めて受けたテスト
問題が全く読めず
０点の答案でした
知識の大切さを教えてくれた
伯母さんのことを思うと
恥ずかしくて
親に隠れて泣いていました
しかし
そこで負ける私ではありません
休みの日も
机と国語学習ドリルとの
にらめっこでした
日本語がずいぶん上達し
在日期間が長い母よりも
日本語が上手になりました
ところが
新たな問題にぶつかるのです
日本語ばかり必死になって勉強し
日本語漬けの毎日を送り
積極的に話す努力をする余りに
母国語と英語の言語能力が
低下していきました
この頃の私は
英語もタガログ語も日本語も
すべてが
中途半端でした
簡単に言葉を変換できなくなったのです
私は何者だろう
どこに所属している人間だろうと
自分のアイデンティティーを見失い
自問自答していました
恐らく
日本に住むことになった
外国人の若者たちは
そう思うことが必ずあると思います
反対に
親などの転勤を理由に
日本から外国へ移住してしまった
日本人の若者でも通る道だと思います
その国の言葉を覚え
文化や習慣を習得し
マイノリティをマジョリティーにするという
同化に飲み込まれ
個性を無くしていく
私はネイティブではありませんが
必死に勉強して身につけた英語を
話すことができます
ここ日本で英語を話すことができる
というのは大きな武器です
だから
多少なりとも自分に自信を
持つことができたのだと思います
そうではない
南米出身者
日本出身者なども
言葉の通じない場所へ急に
移住することになったら
どうでしょう
皆さんがご存知のように
世界共通言語 「英語」の力は
計り知れません
私はこの英語に何度となく助けられ
新しい私のアイデンティティーも
見つけ出すことができたのです
生まれ育った国ではない場所で
自分の価値を確立することは
大きな自信につながります
生きていくベースになると思います
私は大学の授業で
静岡県の人口問題について
考える機会がありました
静岡県は
都心に近いことを理由に
県外に出て行ってしまう人口はなんと
全国ワースト２位
静岡県をはじめ
今後減少し続けていく
日本の人口の
解決策として
私は外国人労働者に
視点を向けました
実際に
浜松市で働いている あるインド出身の方に
お話を聞くことができました
日本での生活についてや
職場の環境について尋ねました
彼は
日本はすごく安全だし
とてもいい国だとお話ししてくれました
その中で１つだけ彼は
不満に思っていたことを
私に教えてくれました
それは
日本は教育費は高いのに
英語教育のレベルがインド程ではない
ということでした
私は彼の話を聞いて
自分自身のことを振り返り
ヒントを得ました
そうだ
私のように
外国人として
浜松市に来た子どもたちに
英語という価値を
与えてあげられる場所を作りたいと思いました
私が通う大学の
学科長であり
多文化専門の
津村教授に相談をすると
即座に賛同してくださり
先生の呼びかけにより集まった
５人の有志生徒で
浜松インターナショナルスクールは始まりました
スクールは授業料が無料です
そして大学から
場所の無償提供を受け
市や企業から
公的補助金の支援を頂いています
主な運営資金は
毎月児童から徴収する
2,500円程度の教材費です
これらを講師の給料に充てています
今後は
講師やボランティア
学生運営者などが確保できれば
平日にも開講し
科目も現在の算数 アートに加え
理科 社会と
増やしていきたいと考えています
そして
現在 学校の運営者である
私たちは４人の学生は
一から校則を作ったり
さらには
毎月のスケジュール
成績表
入学許可証の
作成もしています
保護者へ渡る連絡
講師との教務会議なども
すべて私たち学生が行なっています
もちろんすべて英語での作業です
私たちがもらえる給料は
交通費のみです
しかし
そこで私たちが得られるスキルは
お金には換算できない
価値があります
日本語
母語の習得は大事ですが
残念ながら
グローバリゼーションには対応できません
これからの時代は
多様性を身に付け
国を越えての教育が
必要であると思います
そのためには
英語の習得が
グローバル人材へのカギになります
誰もが
英語圏へ飛び出せるわけではありません
今こういった教育が
日本にいながら
平等に受けられる場を
作っていくことが重要であると思います
私の伯母が言っていたことを思い出します
知識は
誰にも奪われることのない
壊すことができないからこそ
人間が持てる
唯一の最高の財産です
お金がある ない
両親がそろっている そろっていない
日本人 外国人
そんなことは関係なく
誰もが子どもの頃から持てる財産です
ある日すべてを失ってしまったとしても
最後の最後に残るのは
やはり知識です
あなたが身につけた知識は
体の中 心の中に
埋め込まれていきます
ここで皆さんにもう一度 質問をします
私を見てどんなふうに思いますか
13歳で
日本に来て
日本語も分からなかった普通の女の子が
これまで蓄えた知識によって
一歩を踏み出しました
世界は大きく変えることはできないけれども
学び続けていれば きっと
何もしなかった時とは
違う大きな未来が待っています
What helps you
（あなたの人生において）
overcome hardships
（逆境と戦い）
and to continue pursuing
（知識を追及し続けることを）
knowledge in life?
（後押しするのは何ですか？）
For me
（私にとっては）
it's what I was told growing up
（小さい時からのこんな教えでした）
that knowledge is the only asset in life
（知識だけが人生における財産だ）
So never stop learning
（学ぶことをやめてはいけない）
（拍手）